i think number one benefit that i
believe is the flexibility i always
wanted to do an mba
but the whole commute and other things
was a little difficult for me and when
these on-demand courses actually came
when i was doing some research i felt
like the time commitment was short it
fit with my schedule really well
and i was able to
learn something new while not slowing
down on other aspects of my life
the format of the course is very
hands-on it's very practical it's very
structured simple to apply the benefits
of this course that i could think about
is the framework with which i'm thinking
about the problem the business the
competition i'm definitely seeing myself
apply whatever i learned on a day-to-day
basis and it was structured in such a
way that you got to apply a lot of
thinking and that was the fun part every
participant gets their assignments that
they have to submit and if they get the
feedback from the facilitators there is
some reflection with them i was like
very amazed at the breadth of knowledge
that the instructors actually had in
providing very valuable feedback
i was looking for
some guidance frameworks thinking
support in that area so that we can
disrupt our own business the stanford
course enabled me to look from an
outsider point of view on my own
business and it enabled me to
identify growth and optimization that
has been super beneficial to me and to
the leadership team of my company
if you want to learn something these
individual courses are definitely
changing the way one can operate i would
say just don't wait just take it
you